most of the development in the world is
all because of technology
technology has grown much faster than
everything else
all the technology is developed because
of the programming
programming holds a vital role in
development it also includes some
mathematical concepts to make
development more accessible so this is
our key topic in today's session
hey everyone welcome to yet another
exciting video from simply learn in this
session we will be discussing
mathematics for programming however
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn so without
further ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
first we will begin with learning how
mathematics will be helping programming
we shall understand the role of
mathematics and programming and after we
shall focus on learning developments
made using mathematical concepts in
programming finally we will wind up this
session by discussing the benefits of
mathematics in programming
now let's get started with our first
topic
mathematics required for various types
of programming
in programming mathematics is one of the
essential tools to develop applications
and it holds a vital role in development
of applications efficiency
it is tough to create the application
without taking the help of mathematics
every application and development
involves some part of mathematics
mathematics and programming involves
some major topics like linear algebra
probability and statistics and many
others let's discuss them in detail in
the next section
now let's have a look at the role of
mathematics in programming
mathematics in programming involves
various types of concepts like linear
algebra mathematical induction
probability and statistics graph theory
boolean algebra and calculus
let's have a look at them in detail
first we have linear algebra linear
algebra is one of the most critical
domains of mathematics that often comes
in programming
it is especially important for data
scientists because mattresses are widely
used to represent data in any machine
learning program
programmers should be thorough with
various terms like matrix vector
identity matrix transpose inverse linear
equations linear transformations
etc next we have mathematical induction
mathematical induction is extremely
useful in programming
almost any recursion based problem can
be modeled as an underlying mathematical
induction problem
it refers to a data analysis process
that the researcher reads and interprets
raw textual data to develop concepts
themes or a process
probability and statistics probability
is used for domain of machine learning
programming probability and statistics
show up all the time the entire domain
of machine learning is based on
probability and statistics each machine
learning algorithm is modeled by an
underlying probability distribution that
generates the observed data
next we have graph theory
graph theory is another important tool
in programming think about google maps
it is a giant graph
when you navigate from location a to
location b
the underlying algorithms that calculate
the shortest distance are backed up by
various theorems and proofs of graph
theory
some of the notable ones are disrupt
algorithm depth first search breadth
first search topological sorting etc
followed by that we have boolean algebra
programming borrows several concepts of
boolean algebra from mathematics every
programming problem is an underlying
mathematics problem where programming
can be used simply as a tool to perform
computation and obtain the output
various logics like and or
not
or
x nor are concepts of boolean algebra
they're all at the heart of
understanding programming
and lastly we have calculus calculus is
another crucial part of programming
catalyst problems show up practically
all the time in machine learning
calculus is also extensively used in
simulation based programs where various
objects interact with each other the
interaction is modeled by the laws of
physics which are eventually backed up
by heavy mathematics
now let's understand some developments
made using mathematics and programming
mathematics is involved in some of the
major developments like artificial
intelligence machine learning game
development and simulation
let's have a look at the first one that
is artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a branch of
computer science that includes various
numerical methods language theory
programming systems and hardware systems
the three main branches of mathematics
that have a greater career in artificial
intelligence are linear algebra calculus
and probability
it is challenging to become an ai
specialist without any experience in
mathematics
the next one on the list is machine
learning
machine learning in programming involves
four types of critical concepts like
statistics linear algebra probability
and calculus
the core concepts of maths and
statistics are very useful to make
strategic decisions while designing
machine learning models and algorithms
the next one on the list is game
development
one of the biggest advantages of
mathematics using programming is much
needed in the development of games for
their actions and moments
the mathematics involved in game
development are algebra trigonometry
geometry and calculus to angle the
moments in games
the final one in the list is simulation
in programming random numbers are used
for simulation and for other areas the
random numbers and simulation are
helpful in the encryption of the data
number theory and calculus are mostly
used in simulation
now let's have a look at some major
benefits of using mathematics and
programming
mathematics and programming is much
helpful in implementing new and creative
programs and applications it also helps
to build applications in a secure and
speedy manner applications designed and
created using mathematics can show
better intensive performance mathematics
is one of the major reasons behind the
creation of creative and innovative
technology and this was all for today's
session i hope now you guys have an idea
of how mathematics is helping
programming if you have any questions
would you please let us know in the
comment section below we have our
experts to answer it as soon as possible
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here